>> Tucker: VOTERS LAST NIGHT IN
FLORIDA, REPUBLICANS FLIPPED
FIVE MAJORITY LEFT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN BIG COUNTIES,
MIAMI-DADE, SARASOTA, AND MORE.
MIAMI-DADE HAS MORE THAN 300
STUDENTS, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
RON DESANTIS JOINS US.
HE'S THE GOVERNOR.
IT SEEMS LIKE A BIG STORY.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN AND WHAT
DOES IT MEAN?
>> WE MADE A CONCERTED EFFORT ON
THESE RACE, TUCKER, FOR
PRECISELY WHAT YOU SAID, PARENTS
ARE SEEING WHAT'S GOING ON NOW
MORE THAN EVER.
THERE WAS A LOT OF ENERGY.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO HARNESS.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO EDUCATE
OTHER REPUBLICAN VOTERS WHO MAY
BE GRANDPARENTS NOW, MAYBE THEY
DON'T HAVE KIDS IN THE HOUSE
ANYMORE, BUT ALL UNDERSTAND
WE'VE GOT TO GET THIS EDUCATION
STUFF RIGHT.
WE WORKED HARD IN 30 DIFFERENT
RACES.
WE ENDED UP WINNING 25 OF THE
RACES THAT I WAS INVOLVED IN.
AS YOU SAID, SOME OF THAT WAS
SWEEPS TO WHERE YOU HAVE SCHOOL
BOARDS THAT WERE MAJORITY LEFT,
NOW MAJORITY RIGHT.
PART OF THE PROBLEM WE SAW WITH
THIS YOU WOULD HAVE RED
COUNTIES, BUT BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
BOARD RACES UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION ARE NONPARTISAN,
THE UNION WOULD BECOME A
LEFTEST, FUND A LEFTEST, AND
YOU'D HAVE A LEFT WING SCHOOL
BOARD REPRESENTING A
CONSERVATIVE COUNTY.
SO WE HAVE FIXED THAT IN MANY
THESE PLACES TO WHERE THE SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE VALUES OF
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
PEOPLE WEREN'T PAYING ATTENTION.
DID YOU HAVE TROUBLE CONVINCING
PEOPLE THAT THIS WAS WORTH
GETTING INVOLVED IN?
>> I THINK A LITTLE BIT, BUT
WHAT WE DID, WE HAD NO OTHER
RACES ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THERE WAS NO GOVERNOR PRIMARY,
SENATE, ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THIS WAS REALLY IT.
WE HAD A HANDFUL OF LEGISLATIVE
RACES, BUT THIS IS WHAT WE TOLD
VOTERS WERE IMPORTANT.
I DO THINK THAT IT IMPACTED IT.
I THINK OUR TURNOUT OVERALL
WOULD HAVE BEEN LESS HAD THERE
NOT BEEN THIS EFFORT WITH THE
SCHOOL BOARD.
I THINK MORE AND MORE ARE
GETTING THE PICTURE THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
I DO THINK, AS SUCCESSFUL AS IT
WAS, THIS IS JUST STEP ONE.
WE'RE GOING TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THIS GOING FORWARD SO THAT WE
HAVE GOOD CANDIDATES RUNNING IN
THESE SCHOOL BOARD RACES AS A
MATTER OF COURSE.
SO THIS IS PART OF HOW WE'RE
EDUCATING VOTERS, TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE SCHOOL
BOARDS, WHO WANT TO EDUCATE
KIDS, NOT INDOCTRINATE KIDS,
REFLECTIVE OF THE VALUES OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO ASK YOU
QUICKLY ABOUT YOUR RACE.
WE LEARNED LAST TUESDAY THAT
CHARLIE CRIST IS GOING TO BE
YOUR OPPONENT.
CRIST CAME OUT WITH A MESSAGE TO
YOUR SUPPORTERS.
>> THOSE WHO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR SHOULD STAY WITH HIM,
AND I DON'T WANT YOUR VOTE.
IF YOU HAVE THAT HATE IN YOUR
HEART, KEEP IT THERE.
I WANT THE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA WHO CARE ABOUT OUR
STATE.
>> Tucker: HE DOESN'T WANT YOUR
VOTE.
YOU'RE MORALLY BENEATH HIM.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A POLITICIAN SAY
THAT.
>> THIS IS HIS FIFTH DECADE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE, A CHAMELEON,
TYPICAL CAREER POLITICIAN.
TUCKER, PEOPLE SUPPORT ME
BECAUSE I KEPT THE STATE OPENED
AND PROTECTED THEIR JOBS.
CHARLIE CRIST WANTED IT LOCKED
DOWN.
THAT'S NOT HATE IN THEIR HEART.
THEY'RE APPRECIATIVE THEY HAD A
GOVERNOR STANDING UP FOR THEM.
PARENTS AROUND THE STATE SUPPORT
ME BECAUSE WE MADE SURE SCHOOLS
WERE OPEN, THAT THEY GET
EDUCATION, NOT INDOCTRINATION.
THAT'S NOT HATE IN THEIR HEART.
THEY'RE APPRECIATIVE THEY HAVE A
GOVERNOR FIGHTING FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: IT'S WEIRD TO SEE
CHARLIE CRIST LOOK DOWN HIS NOSE
AT VOTERS.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE STATE
MORE MORALLY --
>> I WOULD SAY -- YEAH, I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN.
HE'S NOT ONE TO BE CASTING
STONES.
WHAT HE SAYS, HE CLAIMS, THAT HE
WANTS TO UNIFY FLORIDA.
HE SAYS HE WANTS A FLORIDA FOR
ALL.
THEN YOU CONDEMN A MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THE THING ABOUT WHAT I'VE DONE
IS -- YOU KNOW, WE'VE DONE
ISSUES THAT PEOPLE ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM HAVE BEEN ABLE TO AGREE
ABOUT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT HATING THE OTHER
SIDE, BUT HAVING POLICIES THAT A
MAJORITY CAN AGREE WITH.
>> Tucker: IF YOU DON'T SUPPORT
ME YOU'RE A HAT